man ist einfach fassungslos am tag nach
dem rechtsextremen attentat in halle
erst der versuchte anschlag auf eine
synagoge dann tödliche schüsse auf eine
passantin und einen döner verkäufer
offenbar handelte es sich um einen
einzeltäter der laut bundesinnenminister
seehofer ein antisemitisches motiv hatte
besonders perfide er filmte seine tat
und stellte sie live ins internet
ungeklärt ist heute unter anderem die
frage warum war die synagoge ohne
polizeischutz ausgerechnet an einem der
höchsten jüdischen feiertage
unser top thema heute nach dem
antisemitischen attentat von halle hat
die polizei versagt wie sehr bedrohen
rechtsextreme unsere freiheitliche
gesellschaft das top thema jetzt im zdf
morgenmagazin
zwei tote zwei schwerverletzte das ist
die traurige bilanz des terroranschlags
von halle und es hätte noch viel
schlimmer enden können schließlich
wollte der attentäter die synagoge
stürmen und sprengsätze zünden
andreas weise jetzt über eine stadt
unter schock und viele offene fragen
das paulusviertel in halle an der saale
später abend auf den straßen vor allem
polizisten von journalisten aus aller
welt und einige anwohner erst jetzt
können sie zurück nach hause
man ist aufgewühlt besorgt um die lieben
die man so den ganzen tag zurückgelassen
hatte und ja man hatte mir gedacht das
passiert nicht so im unmittelbaren
umfeld ein video aufgenommen von einem
augenzeugen zeigt was passierte ein mann
im kampfanzug schießt um sich
ein anderer augenzeuge berichtet das war
aber richtig also richtige geschehe sei
da verloren ihre projekte und die stören
hier euro ein das hat mich die
großflächig so mitgekriegt ich wollte
straßen und muss sich erst mal in
deckung gehen
das neue wie wild west kurz danach
stellt sich heraus der täter hatte
versucht in die synagoge im
paulusviertel einzudringen
doch deren türen waren wohl gut
gesichert der täter erschießt einen mann
in einem döner-imbiss in eine frau auf
offener straße zwei weitere passanten
werden schwer verletzt
die lage unübersichtlich später wird von
schießereien in einem ort 15 kilometer
nordöstlich von halle berichtet
schließlich meldet die polizei eine
festnahme am abend macht sich sachsen
anhalts ministerpräsident haseloff vor
ort ein bild von dem was passiert
haben wir danach sicherlich nicht zur
ruhe bis wir das alles sorgt den weg
gebracht haben und verpachtet haben dass
wir mit den opfern mit den angehörigen
und mit der kultusgemeinde und aldingen
jetzt geschockt sind auch in der
stadthalle sozusagen eine gute zukunft
versuchen zu organisieren und das werden
wir morgen mit bundespräsidentin
viele fragen sind noch offen nach der
bluttat von halle auch die ob die
synagoge gut genug geschützt war
gerade rund um den höchsten jüdischen
feiertag jom kippur die
sicherheitsmaßnahmen sind eine
überwachungskamera und gut gesicherte
türen
ansonsten fast jeden tag vorbei beamte
sich da so gut wie nie
bundesanwaltschaft und polizei wollen am
nachmittag nähere details zu tat und
täter bekannt geben
außerdem wollen der bundespräsident der
bundesinnenminister und der vorsitzende
des zentralrates der juden in
deutschland nach halle kommen schalten
wir jetzt als erstes zu unserem reporter
vor ort in halle guten morgen jan
fritsche haben sie inzwischen neue
erkenntnisse über den täter und die
motive naja was bisher fest steht über
den täter ist dass es sich mutmaßlich um
stefan behandeln soll ein 27-jähriger
hier aus sachsen anhalt und die motive
werden so langsam klarer als es kursiert
ein manifest im internet ein
rechtsextremist manifest wo er unter
anderem auch den holocaust leugnet da
wird aber im moment noch geprüft ob es
denn tatsächlich auch von ihm stammt
oder ob es möglicherweise auch eine
fälschung sein könnte außerdem hat er ja
auch die tat gefilmt und teilweise ins
netz gestellt und auch da äußert er sich
immer wieder antisemitisch also da
scheint das motiv schon sehr klar noch
eine richtung zu denen in der nacht gab
es ja auch noch einen polizeieinsatz in
nahegelegenen landsberg was wissen sie
denn darüber
jahns marx am gestern gegen mittag
schüsse gefallen nachdem diese situation
hier in halle vorbei waren gestern in
halle wurde schon gegen abend gegen 18
uhr 18.30 hier erst mal die große
sperrung aufgehoben und die menschen
durften ihre häuser wieder verlassen
diese situation hat in landsberg etwa 15
kilometer von hier eine kleinstadt noch
an gedauert bis spät in die nacht jetzt
hören wir das seit 7
die spurensicherung halbwegs
abgeschlossen ist und die polizisten
nach und nach die stadt verlassen aber
bestätigt ist auch das noch nicht wie
reagieren denn die menschen heute morgen
am tag nach dem attentat was hören was
sehen sie ja ich konnte gerade mit
einigen menschen hier sprechen also
bedrückend ist das wort das ich immer
wieder gehört habe die menschen für sie
ist es hier normalerweise ein ganz
normaler ort sie arbeiten zb gegenüber
der synagoge die wir im hintergrund
sehen in den gebäuden am gestern auch
diese lauten explosionen vernommen
und sie haben sagt gestern war hier noch
alles ganz normal und plötzlich ist
alles anders also das beschäftigt die
menschen auf jeden fall nach wie vor
sehr jan fritsche war das vielen dank
für diese aktuellen informationen leicht
aus halle und damit jetzt weiter nach
aschaffenburg von dort ist uns andrea
lindholz zugeschaltet sie ist csu
bundestagsabgeordnete und vorsitzende
des innenausschusses im bundestag einen
schönen guten morgen frau lindholz guten
morgen
wie haben sie dann reagiert als sie von
dieser tat von diesen ereignissen gehört
haben
also mich hat die tat wie viele andere
bürgerinnen und bürger in diesem land
sehr geschockt und ich würde sagen sie
trifft auch eigentlich unsere
gesellschaft bis ins mark und ich möchte
an dieser stelle vorab zunächst einmal
den angehörigen der opfer mein mitgefühl
aussprechen und den in deutschland
lebenden jüdinnen und juden unserer
unter glaube ich kann ich auch für viele
bürger in diesem land sprechen volle
solidarität
es gibt heute kritik daran dass die
polizei die synagoge nicht geschützt hat
ausgerechnet an jom kippur dem jahr
höchsten jüdischen feiertag wer hat denn
da versagt ihrer meinung nach also es
steht mir nicht zu
hier von dir die die behörden vor ort
und die polizei zu kritisieren in
sachsen anhalt die müssen das vor ort
bewerten aber ich muss sagen die frage
drängt sich natürlich auf warum die
synagoge gestern nicht mehr gesichert
worden ist genau das wird auch mit
sicherheit in den nächsten tagen thema
sein und wir müssen auch darauf eine
antwort erhalten das wird in den
bundesländern unterschiedlich gehandhabt
und ich kann ihnen nur sagen dass dann
nach gestern überall in ganz deutschland
in dem bundesland
die schutzvorrichtungen nach oben
gefahren worden sind aber diese frage
ist absolut berechtigt und der dieser
frage muss auch nachgegangen werden aber
sehen sie es mir bitte nach wenn ich
heute morgen keine bewertung dazu
abgeben
wir haben heute morgen mit
rechtsextremismus experte olaf
sundermeyer gesprochen da möchte ich
jetzt mit ihnen gemeinsam kurz noch mal
reinhören
wenn man sich dieses video anschaut wenn
man diese diesen plan wie er es nennt
den er ins netz gestellt hat sein
manifest wird mit zugrunde legen dass er
tatsächlich dass das tatsächlich die
quelle dieses rechtsextremistischen
täters ist dann sieht man einmal ein
geschlossenes rechtsextremistisches
weltbild aber auf der anderen seite auch
einen jungen mann der auf dem geltung
streben an die öffentlichkeit an eine
internationale öffentlichkeit sich
wendet er spricht englisch in diesem
video das ist ein muster das wir aus
anderen taten international kennen ich
sage el paso ich sage christchurch in
neuseeland in der in der vergangenheit
so weit also herr sundermeier über den
täter und zu dem er sagt er auch noch es
gebe rund 12.000 gewaltbereite
rechtsextreme in deutschland und auch
wir erinnern uns der mord an dem
kasseler regierungspräsident walter
lübcke getötet von einem rechtsextremen
ist ja nicht wirklich lange her wird die
gefahr rechtsextremer gewalttaten immer
noch unterschätzt wir haben verschiedene
extremistische ausbildungsform wir haben
uns lange zeit auch in thun es immer
noch mit dem islamistischen terrorismus
beschäftigt wir haben den
linksextremismus aber wir haben und das
seit 2005 10 thomas de maizière der
damalige innenminister schon darauf
hingewiesen auch steigende tendenz im
bereich rechtsextremismus eine große
herausforderung für alle ist es hier die
unterschiedlichen ausprägungen zu
betrachten wir haben zum einen personen
die genau zugeordnet und von den
behörden auch überwacht werden können
wir haben zum zweiten veränderte
netzstrukturen die wir betrachten die
auch aktuell betrachtet werden
und wir haben zum dritten unglaubliche
vernetzungs und radikalisierung
möglichkeiten im netz
und wenn es so ist dass dieser junge
mann möglicherweise vorher in keiner
weise in erscheinung getreten ist aber
doch ganz klare antisemitische
einstellungen hat dann muss ich sagen
ist ein junger mann mit 27 jahren deren
umfeld hat der familie
dem in seinem leben schon viele menschen
begegnet sind und so etwas so etwas
entwickelt sich und wir müssen auch das
netz genauer betrachten ob es sein
manifest es wird ja derzeit noch geprüft
aber auch da stellt sich die frage wie
können wir sozusagen im vorfeld auch im
netz ich weiß dass das manchen nicht
gefällt wenn man sagt man will als netz
besser kontrollieren
aber das netz darf kein rechtsfreier
raum sein und es muss ein wo es muss
gute beobachtungsmöglichkeiten geben so
wie sie es auch in der realen welt gibt
und diese müssen wir uns widmen
dem können wir uns auch nicht
verschließen und da hat es in den
letzten zehn jahren eine rasante
entwicklung gegeben und diese tat ist
einfach schrecklich und wenn ich mir
überlege mein sohn ist auch anfang 20
der junge mann ist 27 jahre alt wie
entwickeln sich solche gedanken und ich
will sagen als auch unsere gesellschaft
gefordert es beginnt in den schulen
das beginnt beginnt bei der bildung das
beginnt auch damit dass wir unsere
vergangenheit nicht vergessen und frau
lindholz da schließt sich auch noch die
frage daran welche konsequenzen denn
auch die politik jetzt ganz konkret
daraus ziehen kann und muss noch mehr
polizei beispielsweise vor jüdischen
einrichtungen oder härtere strafen bei
antisemitischen taten auf jeden fall
muss die polizei vor ort eine analyse
machen warum die synagoge gäste nicht
geschützt worden ist und ob ihre lage
einschätzung richtig war
in bayern haben wir hier eine ganz klare
ansage von markus söder und auch unsere
politik um die jüdische einrichtungen
geschützt werden und frau knobloch hat
mal gesagt sie fühlt sich in bayern
sicher und das muss unser ziel sein die
menschen in unserem land auch die
jüdinnen und juden müssen sich sicher
fühlen
das ist der eine punkt der zweite punkt
ist natürlich müssen wir auch aus dieser
furchtbaren tat unsere schlüsse ziehen
und müssen einfach schauen ich will noch
mal das netz ansprechen haben unsere
sicherheitsbehörden alle erforderlichen
möglichkeiten um auch im netz
entsprechende recherchen durchführen zu
können um auch entsprechende
durchsuchungen durchführen zu können
sind sie hier gleichgestellt mit ihren
ermittlungsmöglichkeiten in der realen
welt und danach kommen wir damals zur
frage muss sich höhere strafen verhängen
wir haben eine unabhängige justiz wir
leben in einem rechtsstaat ich will auch
die justiz hier nicht bewerten oder
kritisieren das steht mir nicht zu
aber ich glaube das ist ein
tiefgreifendes problem das muss an den
ursachen ansetzen und nicht nur folgen
beseitigen betreiben und die ursachen
die werden ganz früh gesetzt und
deswegen appelliere ich auch noch mal
sehr dafür dass dieses thema auch noch
verstärkter in die bildung unserer
jugend mit einfließen muss andrea
lindholz war dass die vorsitzende des
bundestagsinnenausschusses ich bedanke
mich ganz herzlich für ihre einordnung
an diesem morgen